You are someone who looks very much at the future of the media,
how it can be solved also kind of working within CNN.
What's that like?
Well,
I certainly went through this media ringer and I appreciate you and crystal,
um, and folks like Joe and Sam Harris, uh,
and so many others breakfast club that had me on when I was
not as mainstream, I suppose, and just heard me out and, uh,
talked about my campaign, uh, now being on CNN,
like I have more insight into the goods and bads of how the media works.
Uh, and I, I've been honest saying, look for me,
being on CNN,
I think is very positive because it helps just get my face and voice in front
of, uh,
Americans in a way that can help advance our goals and ideas. Uh,
and I will say being on CNN,
I have never gotten any notes in terms of, Hey,
um, maybe you should try and make this point or feedback being like, Hey,
that point was not great, right. Or go down this direction.
So, uh, you know, on that level, um, it's quite positive,
but I also see that there are incentives wrapped up in the medium that ended
up driving coverage in particular ways.
And that the medium doesn't allow for particular types of conversations or
ideas to get out that might not fit into the rhythm of a
five minute cable news hit, uh,
that in those news hits comprise the vast majority of the coverage,
because the thought is that, well, if you're a TV audience,
like you need to keep things snappy and then kind of get in and out and maybe
have like graphic and video and some other stuff. Uh, so I,
I let's just say that, you know,
being part of the media is just fueling my desire to try to,
uh, change the incentives in ways that'll make.
It work better for more Americans.
Uh, and I,
I say this in particular about the thousand plus local newspapers that went out
of business. So are there issues with cable news? Yes. Major issues.
Uh, but at least they exist. You know, if you have no local paper,
it's very hard to vote on what's going on in your town.
Uh, and so what's going on in media is a,
is a microcosm of what is going wrong in American life,
which is just the market runs everything.
And so if you're like post office doesn't make money, the post office, you know,
like, uh, that local paper didn't make money anymore. Get rid of it. It's like,
well, maybe that local paper actually had some value to the people at that town
beyond the fact that it made money as a private concern to
me,
we have to fix democracy and it's going to be difficult to fix democracy if you
don't have certain types of functioning media organizations and let's talk
the incentives there. Cause.
I've, we've talked a lot here on my podcast.
Just about the way that the media business is changing. You know,
you have first, you had to click ad revenue model.
Of course there was a monopoly on classified ads. Now that's gone with Facebook,
Google, and so much more.
I actually use a line all the time that you think you said on my show,
which is that the internet naturally sex selects from monopolies.
Like nobody wants to use the fourth worst Google the second best Facebook or
whatever.
But so if we're going to live within that system with realities and I've always
appreciated that you're fair, right. That, you know, people actually,
people don't really want to use multiple Facebooks or multiple Googles if we're
going to use, if we're going to live in that world, what do we do with media?
So because how do we actually make it? So,
cause you don't want government subsidized local news either. I mean that,
you know, we're talking about earmarks and pork.
I actually do want, and this is where we disagree.
I do want government subsidized, local news.
Yeah. But how, how would you protect it? Um, how would you protect it from,
you know, legislators who are using it as a bargaining chip?
Like if you look at what's happening right now with voice of America and the
global news agency, there've been all these accusations like, Oh,
Trump put in this person and you know,
even though this person who's been selected by Congress,
so if we were gonna fund it,
like what are the ways that we could do it while keeping it independent with the
essential role that media has and then also protecting it from political
influence? Is it even possible?
I think it is possible.
And I think that there are a few different parties that need to be part of it.
Uh, number one is government. Number two is, uh, nonprofits and NGOs.
And then number three are the media companies.
And I think there's a way you can fund it where let's say, hypothetically,
you said, guess what?
Getting quality information about what's going on in your community is a public
good.
And we're just going to say that there's a certain amount of money that gets
allocated for every concurrent congressional district based on population.
And there's going to be like a local paper that ends up being the beneficiary of
this, or like a local station or whatever, like the local Oregon's are.
And it could be public private, uh, you know, it could even be in some cases,
philanthropic, uh, but that there are different approaches.
These media organizations could a hundred percent exist if they weren't forced
to throw off market level profits every given quarter.
So what do I mean by that? It's like, look, my local paper can't compete,
but if you had a combination, public private,
and you had a paper that made a certain amount of money and then spend that much
money on coverage and it broke even every year,
obviously no one would invest in that because you know,
it's a terrible business, but, uh, as the public would you invest in that?
Probably, I mean, you, you, you know,
you put it in place and then at least you don't have to.
And in my mind it would be worth the subsidy.
I have no problem with subsidizing, uh, local journalism.
And I also think soccer, this is a fundamental issue. Um, and,
and this is where I possibly, and I think I'm clear about is genuinely.
This is probably where you and I disagree. Well, conservatives look up and say,
Hey, you can have government involved with local media because it will become
politicized and a bargaining chip, and they might influence coverage, et cetera,
et cetera. And then I look at it and say, okay,
the current situation is literally zero.
Can you improve on zero? Uh,
and if you have issues around politicization and the rest of it,
you can look around the world and say, look,
are there independent media organizations that are publicly funded that seem
like they're okay, criticizing the government and you would find, yes,
they do exist. You know,
you could hold up the BBC as one potential example and say, that, is it perfect?
No, but does it exist? And a lot of people get value from it. And like,
does it seem fairly independent journalistically and able to critique
leaders? Yeah, sure. Uh, and so the, the,
the correct approach is not in my opinion, just throw up your hands and say,
can't do it. Like government's going to screw it up somehow and said,
you have to get into the weeds of it and say,
look like the current path is leading towards in this case,
total absence of local journalism, which I would argue is very disastrous for,
for democracy.
So then you have to just put your hard hat on and roll up your sleeves and say,
okay, what are the issues we're concerned about?
You don't want politicians to be able to yank funding every time that the news
organization says something nasty about them while then like, let's see,
we can make this funding mechanism independent, uh, of, uh,
of congresses wins. Maybe you have like very long timeframes,
or you can only make changes like X years in advance when like you'd like,
it might not matter to you anyway. Uh, so like that,
that to me is like a more, uh, principled approach. Um, but,
and this is the tough truth as someone who,
and it's fun because I know some people like me because they think I have some
libertarian impulses and leanings and whatnot. Um, like I,
I am very conscious of the fact that there are a lot of things in my opinion,
government is terrible at, and you'd rather not have them involved with it,
but there,
there's also this tough truth that we're in an era where you're going to need
government at a minimum to inject resources into certain
types of institutions or to solve certain types of problems.
Because there's so many problems we have that the market will not have any
interest in solving.
So I actually completely agree with you. And, you know,
people who know me know that it's not about the government intervention
necessarily, that I'm most concerned about.
It's actually that I'm not so sure that we don't have a private sector solution.
And the reason I say that is because I look at somebody like you,
who was born, like I said, with the Joe Rogan of the internet,
I see this burgeoning alternative media ecosystem. I see sub stack.
I see what's happening in Silicon Valley with tech and so much more the
explosion of new businesses and more, and I say, you know what,
there's something going on here. There's a realignment, so to speak, right?
You have changing business, changing media landscape,
changing business landscape.
You're changing political coalitions is like the craziest selection.
And along maybe crazier than the one before that.
So I kind of apply it as a framework towards any everything.
And that's what I mean when I say I look it at the media and I know you're
involved in the tech space as well. I see this explosion of sub stack.
I see this explosion of independent journalists guys, like Matt Taibbi,
Joe Rogan, going to Spotify, the emergence of this whole new culture.
And I'm like, what, what we,
what it's really up to up to is entrepreneurs and others is to find a way in
order to make that work for local news.
And if that actually cannot work and we truly cannot work,
I'm not above the public solution whatsoever.
It's more about jumping towards that a little bit too quickly.
It, it, it can't work brother. No. Uh, the,
the numbers guy has looked at it and said, this is a total disaster. And when,
when companies have invested tens of millions in it, you remember patch,
you know, like it, it was just sending money on fire. Um,
the local papers have all become, uh, you know, desiccated,
husks are disappeared.
And I walked through those offices because I was campaigning in rural Iowa
and New Hampshire and elsewhere.
And so you go interview with a local paper and yes,
what that office looks like now, it's half empty. And, you know,
people are looking around wondering if they're going to survive. Um,
and that's pre pandemic. I mean, post pandemic, this stuff's even worse,
you know,
can you imagine being like a free weekly in Austin or Boston or wherever
trying to survive now? I mean,
it doesn't make any sense like th th the I am, um,
I'm sure that there is no, uh, entrepreneurial market based solution, um,
for local journalism,
unless you were to have something like universal basic income where people had
their needs met, and then if they wanted to, they could write about stuff. Uh,
but even then you would have certain types of journalism that were not included
in that, uh,
because like a local blog is not the same as having a
genuine a news organization. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.